- Hang on to something.
(adventurous music)
We just got a little ray of sunshine -
or should I say lightning? -
because it was just announced
that a "Percy Jackson"
TV series is in the works,
so we're gonna break down
what we might see in that,
right now on The Ketchup.
"Percy Jackson & the Olympians,"
about the adventures
of young demigod Percy,
has been one of the
most popular children's
literature series over the past 15 years.
And now it's becoming
a TV series on Disney+,
where it could become another tentpole
to go alongside shows
like "The Mandalorian"
and perhaps the upcoming Marvel series.
(doorbell rings)
- Wanda, welcome home.
- Now, the author of
the books, Rick Riordan,
along with his wife Becky,
made the big announcement
on Twitter recently by making
this really cute video.
- Percy Jackson is coming to Disney+.
Yes!
- Yes!
- Whoo-hoo!
- [Naz] And also with a
longer statement from Rick.
So, in it, he says they are
excited about "a live-action
series of the highest
quality," adding that it
will follow "the storyline of the original
five-book series, starting
with 'The Lightning Thief'
in season one," which is the first book.
But, as you may remember, this same idea
happened back in 2010, but in movie form,
when the Rotten "Percy
Jackson & the Olympians:
The Lightning Thief," starring
Logan Lerman, hit theaters.
It got decent box office
numbers, but ultimately
rubbed fans the wrong way.
- I used to date your daddy.
- [Naz] That was followed up by 2013's
"Percy Jackson: Sea of
Monsters," also Rotten,
with fans once again not feeling it,
largely due to deviations
from the source material.
So, basically plans for a third film
were scrapped after that.
- That was... awesome!
- But this time around,
Rick seemingly tried
to put fans at ease by suggesting
that this adaptation will
be closer to the books,
saying, "Rest assured
that Becky and I will be
involved in person in
every aspect of the show."
And that seemed to work, because fans
on Twitter are absolutely stoked for this
after waiting so many years,
so thank you, Uncle Rick.
Now, if the series does follow the books
more closely, we should expect to see
a young Percy discovering
his demigod status
and figuring out his
powers in the first season,
and he could be joined
by other characters,
like Grover Underwood, who in the books
is a forest spirit with a human torso,
and Annabeth Chase, a daughter of Athena.
So, in the book, those two join with Percy
to help him clear his name
after Zeus accuses Percy
of stealing his master lightning bolt.
Oh, the demigod drama.
- I swear, I don't know
how that got there.
That's not even my shield!
- Now, it is reportedly
in the early stages
of development, but if it does turn out
to be a hit for Disney+
and sticks to doing
one book per season, they could also pull
from "The Demigod Files"
and "The Demigod Diaries"
for more series material
or for potential spin-offs.
I guess it's up to you, the fans.
Speaking of which, it is time for us
to kick it over to you guys now.
Are you excited for a
"Percy Jackson" TV series,
and if so, who would you like to see cast?
Be sure to leave all your
thoughts and feelings
in the comments section,
and for more streaming news,
be sure to check out RottenTomatoes.com.
Also, don't forget to join
our fan group on Facebook,
because fans really matter
to us, like this one.
- What's up everyone?
My name is Nylene Garcia, and
I am in Riverside, California.
I hope you guys are all
staying safe and staying Fresh.
And if you do not want to miss out on any future episodes of this show
be sure to hit that subscribe button and notification bell
so that you don't miss out on any of the fun!
And as always, thank you so much for watching The Ketchup.
My name is Naz Perez
and we hope to see your face in the next video.
Bye!